all right a live look at the Supreme
Court at this hour where justices just
wrapped arguments in a pair of
challenges to President Biden's 400
billion dollar student loan handout
let's bring in Dave Rubin host of the
Reuben report thank you very much for
joining us David
um so they've taken up Biden's student
loan plan it's estimated this handout
will cost about 400 billion dollars but
it'll be a huge test of the limits of
Presidential Power how do you see this
well I'm not a constitutional lawyer but
I have talked to a couple of
constitutional lawyers and nowhere in
the constitution does it say that the
president of the United States who's in
charge of the executive Wing I mean he's
supposed to sign bills into law Congress
is supposed to write them and then he's
supposed to sign him nowhere in the
constitution does it say he can just
wipe out massive debt of any kind right
I mean I've got 28 years left on a
30-year mortgage I would love if the
president could just sign something and
wipe that out but he can't do that
either I mean the bizarre notion here is
somehow that the President should be
king and should be able to decide who
all the winners and losers are you know
people seem to think or at least the
Democrat line on this is that this would
somehow really help poorer people but
there are plenty of middle class upper
middle class and upper upper class kids
who go to say Syracuse at about 65k a
year rack up about three hundred
thousand dollars of college debt and the
President should be able to wipe that
away I mean there's there's a moral
argument but then of course what you're
talking about is the legal argument and
I just don't see how the Supreme Court
could possibly back this thing it's
simply not written in the Constitution
yeah and well here's the way the
Nebraska Attorney General is taking this
on uh in a lawsuit against the
administration over these student loans
why we're challenging Biden's student
debt power grab the president cannot
have it both ways the Nebraska AG says
he can't tell the country the pandemic
is over while claiming that it justifies
this unilateral action and by the way a
reminder of Nancy Pelosi rewind to 2021
when she said this
people think that the president of the
United States has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power that has
to be an act of Congress well well and
here we are today Dave
I can't believe I'm on Fox News saying
that I agree with Nancy Pelosi hell must
have frozen over over here I'm not even
sure he can delay it or anything else
she said there but but yes we all know
that the president doesn't have this
power technically the real question here
is what pressure will the court face and
how sort of liberally will they look at
the law uh but this is a really really
dangerous precedent that basically any
mistake that you make or not even a
mistake I mean people willingly get into
debt to go to college with the hope of
getting the good job and accomplishing
what they want to in life sometimes that
happens sometimes that doesn't but if
you think the president is the one
that's supposed to bail you out I mean
in general we've become too accustomed
to bailouts as is there's a real problem
here and again it's going to end up
helping a bunch of people who by the
Democrats on argument don't deserve the
help I'm personally for equality not
Equity but that would be their argument
many instances of policies enacted by
this Administration or hurting the very
people they say they're out to help the
most in case in point inflation nation
that is hurting the lower income earners
in this country more than anyone this is
far left Democrat Elon Omer today
backing the president's right to forgive
loans here you go
so the question today is does the
president of the United States have a
the power the legal right to cancel
student debt to that we say
yes and to that point David there's no
question this can be very politically
popular and this is a president who is
likely perhaps soon to announce that
he's running for president again
I mean it's just such a clownish thing
that Omar did there right she's not
saying anything having to do with what
the Constitution actually says or
whether it's legal or not or whether he
has that power she's basically doing
what progressives seem to do with
everything which is we want it a certain
way thus we will figure out a way to
exercise power in that manner she's not
making an argument that it is
constitutionally legal to do so she's
just saying hey this is what we want and
then she gets all her supporters to clap
like seals oh she said yes we say yes
it's it's just nonsense and we've we've
got to be a little bit more mature when
dealing with these things but you know
what if this thing doesn't happen right
so if they don't get rid of the student
debt ilhan Omar and the rest of the
squad and much of the media will be
screaming this is just another reason to
burn down the court so in their way
because they want to burn down the
system so to speak they're going to get
a win out of this either way either they
get the debt relief as unjust as that
may be or they get just more fuel for
their attack on the institutions David
Reuben thank you so much for joining us
on all that appreciate it my pleasure if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell